democrats accused of being outright
delusional after the latest boast from
president biden despite sinking polls in
a tumultuous year of chaos ranging from
afghanistan to the southern border and
now problems with the economy president
biden claims his party is poised to win
big in 2022 and even telling republicans
they need to watch out
now we look at 2022
i want to tell my republican friends get
ready bal you're going in for a problem
we have to keep making the case and if
we do i believe we're going to win let
me say this again for the president
we're going to win in 2022. as democrats
we know what we're for
or republicans don't see it before
anything name me something they are for
they're against everything i don't know
a single solitary world leader
who wouldn't trade the problems a
president united states has for their
problems i don't know a single one
and speaker nancy pelosi is gushing over
the job president biden has been doing
they're blocking every effort to provide
it's an honor and of course a pleasure
to be here at this time of challenge and
with the coronavirus financial
insecurity for families national
disasters our country could not be more
could not be better served than with
this most experienced capable hands than
yours president biden he's just perfect
the timing couldn't be better madam vice
president were inspired by your work for
the people as you continue to be an
invaluable partner to president biden so
while the president and speaker pelosi
are predicting big things squad member
corey bush is preemptively blaming biden
and moderate democrats for potential
losses but that's super interesting
we're going to talk about all of this
let me start with you jesse
they're going to say this no matter what
right because they have to right
but do you get the sense that they
believe it no when the donors are there
you have to say we're gonna win
especially if you have all these
democrats what are you gonna say you
know what
i'm unpopular there's high crime high
covenant cases you guys are on your own
this year
past the eggnog right like that's not
going to keep the police bellied up
right it's like it's like a pep rally
like even if like the team is down four
touchdowns in the fourth quarter like
they're still gonna be pom poms you
gotta you gotta root for the team and i
understand that but he can't blame
republicans it's cinema it's mansion
it's the squad you know it's the blue
dogs they're kind of slowing down his
agenda why would the republican party
strap their
lassos to this train wreck look at this
guy he's unpopular his policies are
making everything worse if he was
popular and he was doing good things you
probably have maybe 10 to 15 senate
democrats joining that agenda but you're
not going to see that and that's clear
nancy pelosi
mr perfect i am old enough to remember
when a couple republicans
were a little uh praiseworthy of donald
trump at a cabinet meeting and it was
like the media frame that is
a bunch of suck-ups to a dictator
remember that whole thing
mr perfect of all people i mean that's
you i mean right i mean we don't use
that word lightly but like only in
politics do do politicians just like go
around and just kiss each other's but
it's like would we do that at this table
you are perfect
and kill me sarcastically it is an honor
yeah only sarcastically we are the king
of sarcasm when it comes to compliments
i would i'm sorry do you want to know oh
sure is i forgot how you may i don't
want to get it in the post-game uh
meeting with you you've been i was like
for hours thank you uh
a couple of things
this is if they called donald trump
perfect we would have laughed out i mean
at this table because no one's perfect
except you uh but but i'm going to just
answer a question with the republicans
for and i'm not in charge of the agenda
but just by listening to the interviews
and talking to some of them they like to
drill uh they would like to get uh the
the energy costs down so they can do
that by getting lng they would have
stopped the nordstrom 2 pipeline they
would have actually went out of their
way to arm the ukrainians and gave to
help them give them a strategy and maybe
put some advisors on the ground to let
the russians know what's going to happen
also they were going to investigate
china and they'd be origin of the covet
virus and they were going to finish the
wall after all we have the receipts it
was paid for that's what they'd be doing
so it's not it's not what are they for
therefore these things that's just off
the top of my head
that's good for off the top of your head
it's very positive though so one of the
things is that they've started to do is
that the buildback better bill has been
languishing for a while it's not going
to pass before christmas and now you
have many democrats who are saying you
know what we should really work on the
voting rights piece of our agenda so
they're shelving buildback better
already so to me that means like the
longer this sits out there the longer he
might look like a lame duck president
before he even gets to his first state
of the union address well he he is like
a lame duck president because even the
new york times is writing an article
about who should run for president
telling him not to run for president
corey bush the uh one of the squad
members or one of the radical uh
congresswomen is saying we're losing in
2022 because of you joe biden
and what we've got are all of these
people who already know that that joe
biden can't be the leader he can't carry
the democrats he kept talking about i
kept saying to myself what is he saying
why is he saying he's going to win what
he was saying was we stand with the
people we've made historic progress
we're going to make sure that's exactly
my point he says things that mean
nothing and yeah republicans are for
nothing oh well we're for law and order
to begin with the were for the wall were
for education work for people making a
responsible salary i mean this guy is
for all for inflation and the bottom
line is yeah i've been in politics i ran
five times you really try to you know
puff things up a little but those people
that he was talking to even they don't
believe it and nancy pelosi coming out
and saying that she is inspired by
kamala harris's work that's a quote
i mean i don't know did she come back
from vietnam
i mean it's all it's all nonsense it's
all smoking mirrors and they're losing
and
the generic palette
congressional ballot has republicans at
a historic high like they've not ever
seen numbers like this so if you are a
republican you should run in vermont
this year you never know republicans
could win everywhere but to me i didn't
take any of that rhetoric seriously to
me it was all you know kind of
flamboyant irony
let's say we're popular ha ha inside
joke and and then go on but i will i
don't know the mechanisms of the economy
i don't pretend to i'm not a businessman
uh you know but i am an investor and the
stock market was up almost 400 points
today uh and it's uh because of you know
it's near historic eyes because of the
fed so if the fed bails out the
democrats maybe our our presumption that
they're going to be routed uh in
november will will be tested uh as
things stand i i don't understand how
you could possibly but be optimistic
holding the hand that the democrats are
holding look what just happened we're
going to talk later in the program about
the mayor of san francisco completely uh
walking away from her policies from a
year ago and as if it never happened i
believe that democrats will do that
increasingly that they'll they'll
they'll just stop corey this isn't
working let's move on corey bush still
still says defund the police and believe
me every time she has a microphone she
says the same thing which joe biden
passes out every time she says they're
also saying things jesse like if you
don't cancel student loan debt you will
not get the democrats to come out to
vote so the the progressives are already
saying you're not going to fire up the
bases young people don't vote in
midterms anyway dana am i right about
that i'm right about that so i don't
think they're going to turn out for joe
biden i don't think that's going to like
drive them to the polls and what so they
have to pay what they were paying a year
ago big deal yeah just to chime in there
are 35 year olds who will be outraged if
all of a sudden the loan that they just
finished paying off was paid off by all
these 23 year olds get their loans paid
off there's a lot of people take great
pride in paying off their debt yeah and
i just think you break that agreement
the one thing i'd like to add out of
everybody that could replace joe biden
the one guy that i think could gavin
newsom
i predicted that that was my prediction
from the last time
but we'll have our own candidate a
republican candidate he can't get enough
from the right or the left to win i'm
going to give you my answer tonight yeah
tucker in the a block so what do you
think of watching i'm gonna tell you
that's the deep tease i'll be on tucker
i'll be talking about this very that is
so deep it's two shows away
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else